almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it we've
previously talked about Donald Trump's
anti-vaccine tendencies and some video
from yesterday reveals that it actually
seems Donald Trump doesn't even
understand vaccinations Trump had the
summit with a bunch of different medical
experts and pharmaceutical CEOs that are
working on vaccines and treatments for
the virus outbreak that we're currently
dealing with I have to refer to it that
way to avoid being demonetised on
YouTube I'll tell you about that later
this week but we'll just call it the
virus outbreak and dr. Leonard Schleifer
from Regeneron pharma is talking to
Trump in this clip we're about to watch
and Trump is just asking the most
uninformed questions that sound like
what a first or second grader would ask
the first time they're learning about
how medicine and vaccinations work take
a look and also it will put it in a
different way make you better quicker
well think of it this way if you if you
get immunized with one of these vaccines
you're gonna make some antibodies to
protect you we're gonna already make
those antibodies and give them to you so
you don't have to go through that whole
process does anybody think that talking
to Trump about antibodies is going to
clear up his perspective on what it is
that's going on and then this is the big
shocker Trump starts to get the idea
that the flu vaccine could be given to
people to protect them from kovat 19
which is just shocking that a wealthy
educated seventy year old man thinks
that a vaccine for the flu would maybe
work on this and Trump has been going
around for two weeks now comparing this
to the flu he knows that these are two
different things but he says don't you
think if we gave people a solid flu
vaccine maybe it would help people with
quote corona and the doctors in the room
say no mr. president that would not work
the same vaccine could not work you take
a solid flu vaccine you don't think that
would have an impact or much of an
impact on corona what about the
chickenpox vaccine maybe that would help
deal with the corona guys he thinks
windmills cause cancer of course he
doesn't understand vaccines or anything
else and what this actually does is it
sheds light onto his anti vaccine
tendencies the anti vaccine crowd when
Trump during the debates sort of
placated the anti-vaccine movement with
some of the things he said the
anti-vaccine movement actually thought
hey maybe this guy is one of us when
Trump invited Bobby Kennedy jr. an anti
vaccine advocate vaccine skeptic maybe
better said to Trump Tower during the
transition period to talk about some
vaccine Commission or whatever I don't
even know that it ever got put together
the anti-vaccine of us it turns out
Trump doesn't even really understands
how vaccines ostensibly work
never mind does he have an understanding
of the arguments made by the anti
vaccine he just has no idea and it's
just sort of like sure anti-vaxxer come
and meet with me and you can see the
look on his face when you watch these
videos he's having trouble even remotely
following the conversation that's taking
place in the room never mind
understanding what the president should
understand in a situation like the one
he's faced with and and when I saw this
video it's shocking and it's it's
visually stunning to see a president so
clueless and in so over his head but at
the same time it's really demoralizing
because this is a problem we're trying
to deal with and you know it it's Trump
next going to suggest let's spray people
with Lysol to either protect them or
ourselves it's actually worse than a
dystopian reality because it's a
flat-out idiocracy and as the numbers
continue to get worse and the
administration seems clueless having a
guy who prays about disease running the
entire thing having a guy who doesn't
even understand vaccines meeting with
pharmaceutical companies I am NOT optim
about the u.s. the White House's role in
all of this what I'm hoping for is that
other countries as well as agencies and
organizations in the u.s. that are
working relatively independent of the
control of the White House will be able
to make some progress and make some
things happen here